centering pass redirected lunging play Cole Smith
did not get it out e the nurse a blast off the BST
rebound score and they have been tested I mean
you're talking top 10 power plays almost every
game back comes forsburg trying to answer wrap
around [Music] score Philip forsberg yesterday
it was a shot by lazan just wide picked up by
O'Reilly Alex Kier skates the center brings it
back to forsberg his shot it's scored plays
there Asheville 0 for one on the afternoon
a good keep in by Noak right at the line now down
low Force work to O'Reilly score trying to thread
it through he can barely maintain his feet and
David hustles around lazon forced to challenge
one score andson came in with a goenda with a
save percentage of 868 now a breakaway chance
for Novak score they threw the arms up nothing
yet Campbell in a full scramble trying to get
the shot here's O'Reilly [Applause] score now
Jersy freezing KRA now bring it up and here
they come maybe a two-on one butelli is in a
little feather pass Boer Stars Brendan Dylan
now shley giveway here Mick Baines got it a
score put home Liam O'Brian and it falls at
the Jets line four Winnipeg players on the Move
Mory Appleton out front of the goal they score
he gets it back from Kari Peretti curls now nikov
who's had a good period HS onto it out front of
the goal and they score melli across one timer
stop rebound they score Lon Krauss a geret he'll
dig after it along the end boards Puck retrieval a
big deal on the power play and the Jets get it one
more time eers out front of the N they score
seeing the jet defenseman get involved Lowry
good feed Appleton spins it back Brendon Dylan
shoots it score put it in behind the goal neita
ryer fires it all the way up for Pon Dyan shoots
and that gets through and they score getting the
wall aspect of their first season in the league
poock denied and van rdik tucks it home po a one
timer Patra closes and wow I think he got one from
the bench his is in the right face officer oh Wide
Open scores Raymond pop to the line for cider
they take away Walman so cop drops off spraw
cider one what a shot finds Coy gains the line
Jake to brus to co and he scores wow a couple
of attempts rman finally all clear we had nothing
left in tank and he finds Lin with speed Lin in a
goal he scar angled back Petri pper pan right in
oh and he fan on he SC Pon it's 4 to [Applause]
three here's C to Comer off the bar scores
spins away from Petri finds the seam Posta
scores he finds Joseph just couldn't let it go
Matthew Joseph turns with it now he fires SC
gets back after it onto his backand lifts it
back for kro they got the cycle going pass
it in the middle batted in by Victor hman
roller that floated in on Johanson and he
punched that one down to the blocker now
it's point point in shoots scores Braden
points dumps that one in this one's back to
the point for Hamond his shot is blocked and
controlled by Celli the quick L up the ice comes
ayot aot up the middle scor Adam Johnson Escape
came up cut him in the neck and he died from
the wom hsb's not sure where that is they've
scored switches with ch Tim St Jacob Bernard
Docker stsa one timer scor good Dr skates
away from Matthew Joseph onto the backand
to stamp GH stos wrist shot scores Steven
stos with a shot and was that tipped clear to
the boards Norris able to keep it in good shot
SC against chan chan took the
puck away from him so it's a
two goal game 53 they score the back
row here's a chance in front all alone
scores and a break for Shen he's in the clear
and he shoots it high on a personal break now a
pass in front cyou he scores Gallagher with it
little Quick Pass for new hook dropped it off
for slomski new hook to slomski in tight scores
into it music's going John they got par Pier he
on Play here's a great move by Thomas he comes in
CHS he scores what a shot by Robert the Thomas and
played out ch and ahead another odd man break for
the blues Kyu in front wide open they score sod
Sensational goal jammed him up pretty good and
he ended up T tripping himself Monahan right at
ker scores and up the middle but kept in bar
knock down and a break for torup Cho he's in
the CLA shorthanded he scores at the same time
he had 10 goals last year in 69 games now Kyro
great move great pass they score Shen is first
of the season in behind the defense and now it's
CA again empty net here for Montreal by the way
BL coming in and they score at the point hands
it off for celd celd throws it to the goal they
score Nick Suzuki I think got his stick on it for
a redirect in front said when you're playing
with neander that that combination has just
been deadly early on he did say he doesn't follow
that list here's a break B marter in scores just
missed power turket scores JJ petka on the power
play and luckily for wall not a leaf skater that
wasn't ready for that going off the back of the
boot either good play by Thompson he's going to
have a partial breakway Thompson takes the shot
scor they slide through though here comes elander
in the slot Matthews scorers on the rush power
play goal game TI down the left side trying to
center it that is knocked down ran Johnson quickly
up for Skinner Skinner down the left side w a fire
scores from two goals down against Montreal and
Tampa trying to W back here and they have Austin
Matthews tried to play it down of the corner
and used his speed but he did not get it past
completely broy now PKA has it in front what
a save rebound they score Matthews fires that
Faceoff wind break back jump scored tipped
in front it's a hatrick for Austin Matthews
PL get it to the front of the net now Skinner for
Thompson over in that far corner off to the right
of the Tron there up top d one timer scores here
comes the shot that's BL SA trying to fight it out
Alex tuck gets in the center fighting for the
puck Alex Tuck's got an empty n scores Rasmus
sandine full blast through Center sandine on the
go tried to split the Defenders Wilson there to
help his Drive SC Tom Wilson then keton switch
the point of attack sandine Jensen back door wide
open Score Sunny Milano left left for the room
and never returned centering pass in front right
idea Maro could not get a stick on it though
quick shot scores from up high kopar out with
Kee and Byfield Flyers get a clear back quickly
Byfield floats it towards the net looking for a
tip score Kings come right back Roy a shot
fought off by Peterson Kopitar for Byfield
out to Roy a shot score tipped in Front Circle
feeds the middle shot do know and he missed the
at oh a great look but Deno missed the target a
bouncing Puck Byfield to Kelly of a shot and he
scores now a turnover in the neutral ice area
cev over the line leaving it and a shot score
moves in on a Defender sanheim but he couldn't
get around the defenseman with the buck now he's
got it back feeds the middle lazat shoots and
scores forv barzel here's barzel quick turn
to the boards marzel opens up Dobson Dobson
cruising backand [Applause] score Paso got
a piece of that pass then got more of it here
comes Holstrom with Paso to score that gives a
chance for barzel to wind it up moving to Horvat
on the entry Horvat barzel barzel [Music] scores
he'll Edge this one in martinook gets to it
behind the net boss lets it go to Chatfield
Chatfield shot through traffic they score
to the can's Blue Line quickly up for fetch
nikov though Carolina not wasting any time cam
AC cross Roy they score that's the difference
between a tie hockey game and still having the
lead now 4 seconds left on the power play they
score Andre fetch nikov first of the year their
first real possession of the Pu here in overtime
and there is that man Marty NES he'll drop
it for AO AO with a lane he shoots he scores
game over Sebastian now Felino Seth Jones fires
that was oh forsling tapped in by Felino on the
rebound and the handoff made to kurashev kurv
shoots knocked Away by stolar and it sights out
who [Applause] scores Dickinson threads the
needle to Taylor Hall saved no score Taylor
Halls first as a Blackhawk and L Stan took
his eye off the pumpkin guess who Conor Bard
scores yes sir Heckman LaRon keeps in for
haggy again Ekman Larson score stenin got
it mahura Veri turns and shoots
SA Rebound in front kachuk scores
Matthew kachuk blocked by either radish or
Donado Donado got her in the boot Kev he
scores the back pass to VC stand on the shot long
pass out to lingren that's def fleing in going
hard to the de DeAndre Miller found tro Push To
The Head get it back from laier here's paner for
The N he scores brought out by Will kolie kie
with pinski and Wheeler wheeler fights an open
man Guston scores blocker save he's lost his
stick mermas fires off the post rebound they
score Felino on the loose Puck gives it to Faber
moving in Faber centers this go Joe Hansson with
it he' only allowed four in the third period
make it five zuka the tip and it's 33 well that
should have definitely been a penalty you're not
allowed to to kick any broken sticks up front Ro
SC this the the future fates of the NHL
but there oh the score paner with a big
shot Justin Schulz Yanni Gore to the goal
line Everly a give back for gourd reset
for Schulz here's bork stran with a shot he
scores intercepted here pil over to Dylan du
things coming in Du shot right ped off
and it's in the Nick they score weager
off a stick captured by Shore there's gourd
out in front they score that's hockey baby
tick tack goal had a bit of trouble with it
the Flames still have it hanit shooting and
scores finds Sharon goic in the corner back
to Zer Zer to the point now Simone to Zadora
arer and it's in the net Here Comes AJ Greer the
flight path is clear rear sto by the flame score
regain by Schwarz York Strand will reset it for
dun around the clock for bers out in front they
score Jaden schwar the crowd fully into it here at
climate pledge Arena pushed out of the Zone it's
coming near the net and they score pushing the
puck over to bers pass blocked Rasmus Anderson
clears and will this go into the net it does a
five on three late in regulation in surrendering
an early goal for or late goal rather from
Mason McTavish here's Smith driving one it
scores Riley Smith over the line he's got Malin
finds him drops it for rust cross I pson centering
and they score get an offensive zone shift
and some momentum rust Barrels in after the
puck centers in front deflected in they score you
let him Freewheel like that with a little chip a
speed I like uh the chances of Russ getting to
those pucks P esta puts it in McDonald able to
keep it in hurdle backand pass de glair he scores
Anthony declare Adam hurdle down low gives him a
nice option as we saw there penguins control off
the draw across it comes the mar and a shot scores
and how about the courtesy of Riley Smith I'll
finish that second here's Crosby stepping ahead
of the pack drops it for lank backhander
scores creating some chances here in the
offensive zone penguins have a chance here it's
nto two onone with aari feeds him aari shooting
and save rebound they score lost the handle
comes back to Carlson steps away from zland
gensel down low rust backhander scores hurdle gets
it through to grin in front for declair now back
to McDonald here's McDonald and he scores theel
gets it free back to the point Joseph One Touch
to lat Tang Raquel smacks it to Smith in front
Malin slams it in hens go right back to work
gensel in front a redirect and Russ chance was
denied it's loose it's in little more than four
minutes gone by here in the second period still
no score stars and Canucks Dakota Joshua in off
sticks in front score Pew suder wide of Hain
in the Canucks will take back possession aonic
with some space he'll walk it in feed it to the
left shot score the golden knights looking for
their first shorty of the Year Stone has a go
off escate here down [Applause] low now McNab
Stone and he'll snap it up for Maro lead pass to
w into the Zone shot score what a shot upstairs
for Jack e and a good look for bra Bal fresh out
of the Penalty Box Stevenson to Stone to carry a
score theore feeds it eel and spin away
from the two skin Theodore keeps it in
right on the line Stone across EO shot
[Applause] score Byam laying it back
to the line but Stone tips it out Stone
trying to get there against Tate Stone to
the nut scores drewan pass intercepted by
dfield up ahead Carlson Rashad score off
to dorv and gorv got a piece of [Applause]
that Carlson and front scores what a pass